[Musik]
und jetzt das heute
journal guten Abend auf den Straßen viel
los auch viele Traktoren unterwegs an
den Bahnhöfen hingegen vieleorts
gähnende lere so sah es aus am ersten
Tag des
lockführerstreiks Versuche der Bahn den
Streik juristisch zu verhindern waren ja
gescheitert und heute war erst der
Auftakt morgen und übermorgen geht es
weiter laut Bahn werden im Fernverkehr
rund 80% der Züge ausfallen auch bei
Güterzügen und im Regionalverkehr gibt
es erhebliche Beeinträchtigungen Andrea
Mäuser
berichtet wer heute Bahn fahren wollte
brauchte gute Nerven und gute
Informationen seit 2 Uhr nachts für der
Personenverkehr der Deutschen Bahn
bestreikt und das heißt
arbeitskampfstattgespräche Knackpunkt
die Forderung nach vollem Lohnausgleich
bei weniger Arbeit wir haben am
vergangenen Freitag ein Angebot gemacht
wo wir auf die GDL einen großen Schritt
zugemacht haben in Sachen Arbeitszeit
was ja auch ein kerntha für die
Gewerkschaft der Lockführer ist und
dieses Angebot liegt auf dem Tisch
eigentlich wäre es jetzt daran darüber
zu verhandeln die Bahn muss Angebote
machen und die Menschen hier in diesem
Land nie weiter täuschen und ihnen was
vorgaugeln die muss Angebote machen die
substanziell sind wir sind bereit
Kompromisse zu bilden und die
Wochenarbeitszeit schrittweise
abzusenken s dass die Arbeitgeberseite
Gelegenheit hat auch auszubilden einer
der die Ausbildung zum Lockführer vor
gut 20 Jahren gemacht hat ist Karl
nienhold auch er ist für den Streik
weniger wegen des Geldes was ihm zusetzt
sind die schwierigen Arbeitszeiten jeden
Tag wann anders sehr früh zum Teil vor 3
Uhr Dienst beginegnen oder sie machen
eine Nachtschicht und müssen dann halt
bis um 6 bis um 7 arbeiten das geht
schon irgendwie an die Konsistenz und
natürlich haben sie die ganze
Verantwortung für die für die Menschen
we gerade die vielen Fahrgäste die wir
haben und dann natürlich haben die Züge
ja auch Züge und Materialen erheblichen
Sachwert gestreikt werden soll bis
Freitag 18 Uhr wenn bis dahin kein
Angebot der Bahn vorliegt will die GDL
mit ihrem Streik weitermachen nach einer
kleinen
Pause das recherchezentrum Korrektiv
sorgt heute für fore mit seinem Bericht
wie sich einflussreiche Funktionäre der
AFD sowie zwei CDU Mitglieder aus dem
Verein werteunion heimlich mit Martin
selner trafen dem österreichischen
Rechtsextremisten dessen identitäre
Bewegung vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird dieser habe einen
sogenannten Masterplan präsentiert
geplant seit zum einen die Deportation
von Millionen Menschen auch solcher mit
deutscher Staatsbürgerschaft außerdem
soll viel Geld in die Hand genommen
werden um das gesellschaftliche Klima
medial zu beeinflussen etwa indem die
Legitimität demokratischer schawalen
angezweifelt oder rechtsstaatliche
Institutionen wie Verfassungsgerichte
diskreditiert werden Thomas Reichard und
Ulrich Stoll
berichten es ist ein kalter Novembertag
an dem im Landhaus adlom bei pozdam rund
30 Personen zu einem geheimen Treffen
zusammenkommen mit dabei hochrangige AFD
Mitglieder wie ulldrich Siegmund
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD in
SachsenAnhalt das recherchezentrum
Korrektiv konnte hier verdeckt Drehen an
dem Abend geht es um die Idee Millionen
Menschen abzuschieben auf solche mit
deutschem Pass die Einladung verspricht
einen Zitat Masterplan zur sogenannten
Remigration kein geringerer als Martin
selner werde das Vorstellen höchst
vertraulich das ist selner bei dem
Treffen Leitfigur der rechtsextrem
identitären Bewegung selners Plan sieht
vor auch politisch missliebige Menschen
nach Afrika abzuschieben hier zeigt sich
dass selbst hochrangige AFD Politiker
Position radikal rechtsradikale Position
vertreten haben in einem abgeschlossenen
Raum die sie nach außen hin nie
wiedergeben würden und das zeigt
natürlich die Radikalität im Inneren
dieser Partei bei dem Treffen ist auch
der frühere AFD Fraktionsgeschäftsführer
Roland Hartwig angeblich wusste er nicht
dass sner Auftritt Hartwig ist ein enger
Vertrauter von Bundessprecherin Alis
Weidel sie äußert sich heute nur
schriftlich die AFD wird ihre Haltung zu
ein wanderungspolitik die im
Parteiprogramm nachzulesen ist und die
vollständig im Einklang mit dem
Grundgesetz steht nicht abändern doch im
Netz greift die AFD genau diese Rhetorik
auf das zeigt eindeutig dass die AFD
entgegen aller Beteuerungen sich viel
weiter im Rechtsextremismus
radikalisiert und wir dürfen auch nichts
ausschließen bis hin zu einem möglichen
Verbotsverfahren so könnte das heimliche
Treffen brisant werden für ein mögliches
Verbot der
AFD immer heute journal Update gibt es
dazu nachher noch ein Gespräch mit einem
korrektivreporter der an diesen
Recherchen und verdeckten Dreharbeiten
beteiligt war wie man die Offenheit
parlamentarischer Demokratien nutzen
kann um Macht zu erlangen zu
missbrauchen und nach Möglichkeit nicht
wieder abzugeben ließ sich unter anderem
in Polen beobachten die Rezepte für den
Weg in den
Autoritarismus sind dabei immer die
gleichen und sie zielen vor allem auf
die Unabhängigkeit von Rundfunk
Gerichten und
Beamtenapparat das erschwert dann
irgendwann auch jeden Regierungswechsel
der in einer Demokratie ja eigentlich
ein normaler und kein dramatischer
Vorgang sein sollte eine Herausforderung
für den neuen Regierungschef Donald Tusk
der in Präsident duda zudem einen
mächtigen Gegenspieler hat aus Warschau
Natalie
Steker Unterstützung von den peace
Kollegen es ist der Tag nach dem Finale
gefängnisurteil im Dezember gegen
exinnenminister Kaminski seitdem wartete
Polen wann er und sein exstaatssekretär
abgeführt werden hier fahren Sie doch
woher sie kommen ist beachtlich denn
Präsident duda pesn hatte sie gestern
demonstrativ in den Palast geholt er
hatte sie 2015 begnadigt umstritten weil
damals das Berufungsverfahren
li ef erschüttert dass sie inhaftiert
wurden trotz der präsidentiellen
Begnadigung die peacepitiker sind
rechtmäßig verurteilt wegen früheren
Amtsmissbrauchs doch peace parteichf
Kinski versucht sie als politische
verhaftete zu verkaufen er und ein paar
ihm treue ziehen in der Nacht
demonstrativ zur
Polizeistation die nutzt das aus um den
Eindruck von Instabilität Unsicherheit
und Chos zu ercken weil sie hofft dass
sich das auf lange Sicht auszahlt man
wird sehen ich glaube es
nicht zwischenzeitlicher Zufluchtsort
Präsidentenpalast für verurteilte
Politiker Ministerpräsident Donald Tusk
empört es ist der Versuch einer
Doppelherrschaft mit einem Engagement
der höchsten staatlichen Institution das
ist eine offensichtliche
Sabotage Präsident duda ist die letzte
Hoffnung der peace die sich als Opfer
sieht vom Kurs der neuen Liberalen
tuskreierung bei der Rückkehr zu
demokratischen
Werten und jetzt macht Heinz Wolf weiter
mit den Nachrichten auch heute gab es
wieder Protestaktionen von Landwirten
und bauernpräsident ruckwied kritisierte
am Morgen im ZDF erneut die
Bundesregierung und sagte man behalte
sich weitere Schritte vor einer der
Schwerpunkte der Demonstrationen heute
drden bei einer Kundgebung in elwangen
in badenwürtemberg betonte Agrarminister
östemir dass eine teilweise Rücknahme
der ursprünglichen Kürzungspläne der
Regierung erreicht worden
sei die Bundesregierung hat bestätigt
dass die Lieferung von 150
Lenkflugkörpern des Typs Iris t an
Saudi-Arabien genehmigt worden ist
Außenministerin berbock hatte vor
wenigen Tagen bei ihrer nostreise darauf
verwiesen dass saudiarabi zur Sicherheit
Israels Beitrage indem es Raketen
abfange mit denen die huis im Jemen
Israel
beschießen in Ecuador sind bewaffnete
während einer Live Übertragung in die
Räume eines staatlichen TV-Senders
eingedrungen mehrere Journalisten und
Mitarbeiter wurden als Geiseln genommen
die Polizei brachte den Fernsehsender
später wieder unter Kontrolle und nahm
13 Verdächtige fest in ador nim seit
einiger Zeit die Gewalt durch kriminelle
Banden massiv zu seit Montag gilt im
Land der
Ausnahmezustand zum Auftrag des Biathlon
Weltcups in rupolding kam die deutsche
Frauenstaffel heute auf das Podest Rang
3 hinter den Teams aus Frankreich und
Schweden und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto
am Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewehr 3 7 21 24 37 29 und die Superzahl
9 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdfde und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 und noch kurz die Wetteraussichten
für morgen im Norden und Osten meist
stark bewölkt auch am Alpenrand Lokal
länger drübe sonst viel Sonne
Höchstwerte -4 bis + 4° und in den
nächsten Tagen im Norden bewölkt und
etwas Regen oder Schnee mit Glättegefahr
im Süden größere sonnige Abschnitte -1
bis +
6°. das war's auch schon von uns bevor
es gleich weitergeht in der Düsseldorfer
Arena und wir melden uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
wiedersehen